we're told that cara had a tower with 42
blocks
she added 12
red blocks
14
more blue blocks
and 16
purple blocks so what we want to do in
this video is think about how many total
blocks cara now has and to help us with
that we are going to set up a little bit
of a number line here and this number
line it keeps going in both directions
and i'm going to set it up so that this
big thick hash mark here is
40. i want to make sure that i can
include 42 here and you can see we go 41
42 43 44 45 46 47 48 49 50. so each of
the thick ones are 10 more so that's 50
60
70
and 80.
what i'd like you to do is pause this
video think about where 42 is on this
number line and then think about how do
we add these blocks on this number line
to think about how many total blocks
cara now has
all right now let's do this together so
let's start with her starting point the
42 blocks right over here
so we see this is 40 so we go 41 42 so
this right over here is kara's starting
point that is 42
blocks
now first she adds 12 red blocks so you
could just count on the number line so
if you add
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
you get right over there so this right
over here is
all of us adding 12 blocks now where
does that get us to well we can see that
we are now 1 2 3 4 past 50. so we are
now at 54
right over there and you could have done
it another way you could have just added
right from the get-go you could have
said all right i'm going to add 12 so it
takes me 8 to get to 50 and then i have
4 more left gets me to 54.
and then we need to add those 14 more
blue box so let's add 14 from here 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 gets us right
over there so we add another 14
we get
over there and now what number are we at
well there's two ways to think about it
you can see that we are one two three
four five six seven eight above 60 which
would tell us where it's 68 or you could
see that we are two below 70 which would
also be 68 so we're now at a 68 total
blocks and then we add the 16 purple
blocks so let's do that let's add 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14
15 16 and we get right over there we're
very lucky that our number line just
happened to have the right number of
marks right over here so then we add
16
and we can see that we are 1 2 3 4 past
80. so we're at 84 total blocks another
way you could have thought about it is
it would have taken us two blocks to go
to 70 then we would have 14 left another
10 to get to 80 and then we would have
four left and then you get to 84. but
now cara has a total of 84 blocks